thousands of unemployment claimants are
starting to get a bit worried denise
yeah that's right brian puah claimants
say they were under the impression that
they would be getting
additional weeks of benefits but as time
goes on there is really no answer as to
what's going to happen joe moeller
explains
i have exhausted my 50 weeks about four
weeks ago i think
martin rendu has been collecting
unemployment since the pool program
began
recently his benefits ran out nevada has
set
stated in a theater press release that
it would be adding an additional seven
weeks
but that has yet to be heard of raju is
talking about this january 7th press
release dieter states due to nevada's
high average insured unemployment rate
the state is currently able to offer an
additional seven weeks of benefits
bringing the total benefit weeks to 57
weeks
every week more and more people are
hitting the 50-week mark and are
wondering if the extra seven weeks
will happen is it over you know do now
is it
up to us to figure it out the confusion
is growing on unemployment facebook
groups
it just seems like all communication is
kind of just in some ways dropped off
about what is happening on that
amber hansen runs one of those facebook
pages with tens of thousands of members
there are people out there including
myself that do not know if they are
going to be getting money because
the suicide is saying that there is only
50 weeks available when the press
release states that there's 57 weeks
available
we reached out to dieter monday they
told us under federal law pool claimants
are only allowed to get 50 weeks of
benefits
and so it's just very confusing because
it leaves people wondering
what is supposed to happen joe muller 8
news now joe thank you and we did follow
up with dieter again to get
clarification
on why the press release stated 57 weeks
as of airtime we have not heard back we
will stay on top of it and update you
when we learn a little bit more